now that the races that most people are
watching closely here in America are
Pennsylvania where John fetterman can't
talk and uh
Herschel Walker in Georgia who can't
think so it's a great election uh and
Herschel
Herschel gave his closing argument he
wants people to understand his
Redemption story hopes they are
sympathetic to what he you know he's
very pro-life but keeps having abortions
paid for
uh and he closes his end by looking
right into the camera and saying hey
it's not like I aborted you
it's a crazy election
but uh yeah this is the time what they
call the closing arguments at the party
the Democrats closing argument seems to
be vote for the Democrats or else will
lose democracy
and the Republican closing argument
seems to be vote Republican or we will
hit your husband in the head with a
hammer
I mean this is getting really chippy out
there I mean you saw this if you missed
the story The Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi was out of town and somebody
broke in to try to get her and attacked
her husband the good news Paul Pelosi is
out of the hospital so I think that's
good
not as bad as we thought but this guy
this nut broken and he wanted to kidnap
Nancy Pelosi and then he wanted to
interrogate her and if she told the
truth he'd let her go
and if she lied he was going to break
her kneecaps this is terrifying on on
the other hand I'd give did give Fox
News an idea for a new game show
Fox News
oh I kid fox it is but really the way
they're downplaying this now they're
saying it was just a trick-or-treat that
got out of hand I mean
and
of course it brings out all the
conspiracy theorists some of them say
because Paul Pelosi was going to bed so
he was in his underwear so another thing
they were gay lovers the attacker and
him were gay lovers that's their Theory
they're like come on it is San Francisco
and he didn't come in the back door
I have no shame of these people